foreign
[Music]
s and you know whenever he passes away
it could be as I was saying you know
something is 105 so we could have
another uh 35 years death of Stalin next
one will be death of C hello and welcome
to Chinese Whispers with me Cindy you
every episode I'll be talking to
journalist experts and long time China
Watchers about the latest in Chinese
politics society and more there'll be a
smattering of History to catch you up on
the background knowledge and some
context as well how did the Chinese see
these issues this week Xi Jinping has
taken his new politburo standing
committee on a group field trip to Yan
the Revolutionary base of Mao zedon's
Communist party after the Long March the
symbolism is easy to see on this episode
of Chinese Whispers I've asked back Bill
Bishop who runs the popular cynicism
newsletter and Professor Victor XI
author of coalitions of the week to talk
about the party Congress that's just
finished you might remember that we
talked about the party Congress a few
episodes ago before it started so I
would highly recommend listeners go
check that one out too Victor Bill
welcome back to Chinese Whispers
um let's start with the Personnel first
which we talked about a lot last time we
speculated that she might have to
bargain to in order to stay in position
for longer he might have to give some
positions to people from other corners
of the party but Bill as you've written
about it seems to be a tone she is
running the table he's taken all the
winnings so he hasn't basically given
anything to anyone else that he didn't
want to that's what it looks like from
uh both from the composition of the
Central Committee and then through to
the pilot Bureau and the understanding
committee I mean I think that
um you know and I really want to hear
what Victor thinks but it looks like
there there was no even pretense of any
sort of a balancing or moderating with
other other significant interests if
there are any left in the system and so
from a Personnel perspective I think she
got what he wanted from you know the
revised party Constitution was just
issued and it isn't clear yet that he
got everything on in that have actually
haven't fully digested it but Personnel
wise I think it does look like a like a
running the table
um well Victor let me bring you in here
what did you make of it and also do we
glean from this that she has more power
in the party than we thought he did two
weeks ago well I you know I think
um I had suspected that he could do that
but I thought he would do it a first of
all you know I thought he would do it in
a more
um kind of legalistic way than he did
um so you know as as I uh speculated
earlier I thought he might have changed
the retirement age you know to one year
earlier then uh he could have expelled
um the kitchen and long Young from the
popular standing committee but uh then
he would also have to move uh Wang
hooning out of the Paul real setting
committee but as it turns out
um he just did it you know purely
according to his own preference uh
without
any kind of reference Journey rules or
you know Norms that you could think of
so you know the three people who got
moved up
and Tai Chi
they you know as bill was joking earlier
I mean they were of kind of personal
secretaries to him in the past and sort
of past three stages of his career
um then you had lishi uh and well
geology was there already
who uh were these family friends
basically you know Friends of the family
people would work for
or related to other people uh to people
close to his father
uh and sort of uh whom he had known for
decades and decades trusted by him
um and then Zhang yosha was the big Norm
busting one I mean the guy is 72
he got reappointed to the public Bureau
prison and also the central military
Commission
uh typically people in the military they
do retire later for their level but
still I mean John Young that's we
haven't seen anything like this since
the 90s really
um so yeah there's no just purely his
preference no reference to uh
any Norm shifts or anything
and the other age sort of noticeable age
kind of Norm busting was Wang Yi on the
polypero
right who who looks like he'll take over
from as the as the head of the Foreign
Affairs commission as their top Diplomat
and if those Norms had held he I think
he's 69 he would have aged out
yeah because because the norm had been
if you're 68 or over you would be
retired but of course we have some
people under 68 um who were retired
anyways but we'll come on to that just
on the on on sees men for now
um bill
oh some of these people qualified or
competent to do the jobs that they
possibly are being lined up to do so for
example people point to uh Tai Chi not
having much central government
experience or any central government
experience they point to people like Lee
town the former Shanghai party secretary
who you know oversaw this horrific and
inhumane prolonged lockdown in Shanghai
earlier this this year it seems like
loyalty comes above Merit in in this
instance or Merit is loyalty is Merit
um depending on how no but it's
seriously like you look at someone like
Lee Chong I think before the Shanghai
lockdown disaster
um plenty people thought he was
competent you know he's run Shaha he's
run zhangsu Province he was I think
governor of joseong Province so he's
been number one and number two in three
of the largest economic
um sort of centers of China each of each
of which I think is bigger than most
European countries in terms of economic
output
um so it's hard to say that he's not a
competent bureaucrat up to a point
clearly the Shanghai lockdown was a
disaster and I do think it it does to
your earlier point
remind everyone that this idea of
meritocracy is is either does it really
matter or meritocracy it's a different
kind of Merit which is more like loyalty
and closest to she because of his
long-standing ties with she so you know
I think what I was surprised he got not
only Premiere but he's also number two
in the hierarchy right he was vaulted
you know he went above geology above
Wahoo ning you know people with more
more seniority in the party and on the
standing committee uh a Tai Chi is one
where again he's run he's run Beijing
he's he's has a long experience in the
government you know he's he's clearly a
competent bureaucrat and and
um administrator I mean his his time in
Beijing he did a very good job with
kovid he's done a very good job of covet
he did have the incident I think it was
was 2017 where they after there was a
big fire
um in southern Beijing they cleaned out
uh tens of thousands of Migrant workers
in the middle of winter
and just basically kick them out and a
lot of people you know it was literally
in the middle of winter
um and again that looked like it was
incompetent but maybe that was what she
wanted and he did his job
and Victor is something that we talked
about on on the last time we spoke which
is about what these people believe in
and whether or not that ideology really
matters when it comes to policy like are
they split by policy differences or is
it just patronage differences for
someone like detail I thought it was
interesting that some of the business
Community particularly in Shanghai where
he had been known thought that oh maybe
this is a good thing for those who
believe in marketization those who
believe in trade because Lita had had a
reputation for being good for business
does that matter now was it ever deeply
held convictions
um is that going to change the way that
China has been governed at all yeah I
think the dynamic uh will be different
between Shanghai and his new position as
to premiere of China
uh in Shanghai you know just because I
think Xi Jinping as one person he can't
possibly pay attention to all the
nitty-gritty details
in every you know part of China there
might have been some room for Lee town
to enact some policies or informally you
know give more leeway to businesses
um as the premier of China on the other
hand
I think
um you know he's enacting National level
policies that are more likely to be
reviewed and and approved by Xi Jinping
himself
um so
you know if she's in paying favors One
Direction or another he of course has no
choice but to implement uh policies
according to xiomping's wishes is there
some flexibility on his part I think
there still will be some flexibility on
his part
um to interpret uh you know what common
prosperity for example mean
um
but there are some very clear things
that Xi Jinping would like as outlined
in the political work report uh it looks
like higher taxes are coming you know
for the wealthy in China because uh this
was explicitly mentioned in the
political work report so
um I don't know maybe that explains like
the market crash and all that kind of
stuff right after this
and Bill let's talk about the work
report because as Victor
um has mentioned just now we we saw a
little bit about the future economic
policy in that common Prosperity was
mentioned and that's this evening out of
inequality in China what else was
notable from the work report to you
um well there was certainly also I think
there was a phrase that
seemed to freak some people out around
sort of regulating wealth accumulation
I'm paraphrasing
um and and that got a lot of notice in
general the the Seas report to the
Congress I think
um you know a lot of the themes were
ones that shouldn't have been a surprise
they they really built on top of like
the the sixth plenum last year the
historical as the third historical
resolution uh various things he and the
party have been saying I think you know
the the focus a lot of focus on security
a lot of focus on
um sort of technology self-sufficiency
and then there was that uh the changing
of the language around this concept of
period of strategic opportunity to which
is sort of
the idea that China had a relatively
benign security environment in which it
could develop I'm simplifying here to
one that is now it's sort of both
there's opportunity and there are lots
more challenges and so it's a general I
think an indication of a of a real shift
in the assessment of their external
environment to one that is much more uh
challenging and in some cases
potentially hostile to China and left
unsaid but clearly the driver of many of
these teams was the U.S China
relationship and how bad it's gotten and
I think how how much worse uh the the
leadership in Beijing thinks it may get
and Victor and of course a continuation
of zero covert as well
uh yeah yeah um
well so to me I'm a little bit more
optimistic I mean first of all there has
been some mild relaxation of covert
policies
vis-a-vis the foreign business Community
um they're supposedly gonna get like
expedited uh quarantine I don't know
what that means you know if there's a
quarantine how can it be expedited
uh
but but to me the one encouraging sign
was that at the beginning of the speech
of course it declared yet again zero
covet was the right thing to do uh you
know Victoria's policy uh but in the
rest of the speech in the political work
report there actually was not a lot of
explicit discussion on zero covet
um there was some wording you know kind
of more vague wording like oh you know
we have to do better in disease
prevention and dealing with diseases and
and so and so forth
um but not I mean I would have dreaded
you know a whole paragraph on
like you know we must continue zero
covet in the next five years uh all
cadres you know up and down the party
must resolutely follow this policy uh
that kind of wording uh did not appear
so uh at least so I still think zero
covert will last for another year at
least but uh it provides some
flexibility for uh more relaxation down
the road uh but of course I don't think
that there's going to be any meaningful
relaxation until there's a mass
vaccination campaign or a booster
campaign uh and it's just not evident at
this point
yeah Bill were you hoping or expecting
for zero cover to be finished earlier
no I I agree with what Victor said I
mean it was in there but it wasn't it
wasn't you know that it sort of leaves
some hope that it will be tweaked and
calibrated but not so much hope that
it's going away anytime soon and what
about on Taiwan because that's something
that Western media has picked up
on refusal to rule out force in
reunifying Taiwan is that significant at
all um bill
um I mean the language in the in the
report the decision being gave to the
party Congress I don't think there was
anything new was there um around Taiwan
and so you know the the there is no it's
interesting here in DC especially
there's a real
um kind of a frenzy that you know
they've moved up the timeline they're
accelerating their timeline for taking
Taiwan and yet in the actual documents
um there's nothing that that sort of
indicates that they've made that
decision and so I don't think from a
from a Taiwan perspective the work
report itself was a it indicated any
sort of a significant uh shift in policy
I mean there is this idea that to to
achieve the great sort of Rejuvenation
of China
Taiwan has to be returned to the
motherland and the target for the
Rejuvenation is 2049 so people say well
then it has to happen by 2049 27 years
from now
um that could that's sort of the only
obvious sort of inferred timeline in
there
but Victor can I can I you know before
that you respond to Bill can I also add
lay down an additional Gauntlet which is
that now that c is confirmed confirmed
in a another at least we think I mean I
don't even know if we can say it's five
years or ten years or however long it is
the second decade at least that he is
starting
um does that give it a time limit as
well because is he going to be one to be
the person who does this he manages to
solve the Taiwan problem
um yeah I think he does one and
um I mean frankly I think the Personnel
lineup
suggests it also in fact it's suggested
for the next five years sometimes
because if you think about it why do you
want
people whom you trust absolutely to fill
every single important position
uh including you know Vice chairman of
the CMC
uh as well as public real estate
committee but then of course people who
are now in charge of National Security
issues and the municipal Republic
security
um you know there's been some discussion
by Sheena greiten and others on the fact
that there are now two security people
close to XI in the Secretariat uh long
Xiao Hong and uh
[Music]
um what's the advantage of having that
right so because even Chairman Mao
didn't do this so Chairman Mao had these
puppet figures from the old guard in the
politburo even in during the cultural
revolution because it's always helpful
to have this facade of collective
leadership and if things go wrong you
can say oh we collectively bear the
responsibility
um but she didn't go for that she wanted
you know completely his own people so
then if things were to go wrong he
himself would bear responsibility but
then he doesn't care
uh an advantage of having that is that
you can make very extreme policies right
so whatever extreme policies he enacts
no one is going to say no or try to
undermine it you know basically the
people whom he trusts at least at that
level they will uh presumably do the
best to implement whatever extreme
policy he chooses
um and of course Taiwan is the most
plausible extreme policies that he could
uh enact but it doesn't mean that he'll
do it right so you know it's like he's
lining things up maybe he won't do
anything
and Victor just on that and with your
hat on of comparing to Mao and previous
leaders has Xi Jinping made taken away
one source of resilience for the party
because I had always thought that given
that this is an authoritarian party if
they can manage peaceful transition or
if they can manage internal
um balancing and checking mechanisms
then it actually is more resilient than
a one-person dictatorship but he's taken
that away and he's got yes men around
him so does he actually make the party
less secure by doing this kind of lineup
oh yeah of course
um well so this is a case where but but
you know dictators do that they they
actually don't care uh about the
long-term fate of the party I mean
despite what they say is like oh I'm
setting the party up in the next
Thousand Years etc etc
the way
um you know because by arranging
politics this way you actually weaken
the institutions uh because basically
people under you they have no incentive
to build up their own power their own uh
institution institutional base because
the moment you do that you make the
dictator suspicious you get purged
um and then also as he gets older
politics will be very very personal as
uh personalistic because uh he's going
to be sick he's going to lay in his you
know bed or something like that and
basically all the decision making has to
work around him and so you know all
these pretends of political meetings and
all this kind of stuff will go out the
window
um yeah no he's weakening institutions
and um you know whenever he passes away
it could be as I was saying you know
something is 105 so we we could have uh
another uh 35 years death of Stalin next
one will be death of see no it's a um
the other thing to write the two
victories it's not like there won't be
factions now there's going to be I think
we should expect lots of infighting
among quote unquote she's men right is
the hockey for well especially in the in
the security apparati I feel like there
will be incredible just infighting in
all these agencies between agencies
within agency
um yeah I don't know how that's going to
be manageable but but exactly so
basically as we're saying there's so
many disadvantages to what he's doing
and so you really have to think about
what are the advantages of doing that
um well just just briefly Victor why do
you think there will be so much in
fighting especially around among the
security operators oh I mean so I I have
to say you know Xi Jinping is a
brilliant politician
Wang Xiao home for example extremely
powerful now as minister of public
security uh got into the Secretariat but
not the pilot Bureau uh I don't think he
got in Palo Vero
uh
presumably will be Jean-Claude
but then uh equal to Wang xiaohong in
the Secretariat so they're both members
of it
um so those two will Clash because now
what's what the political work reports
said I mean the part of the reason why
there was so many mentions of uh anchen
security was that there was a pretty
long section about how National Security
risks have to be managed in the future
you know there's an integrated
examination of external and internal
threat what does that mean you know you
do have these two agencies MSS
um MPS they will share a lot of
jurisdictions there's I mean it's it's
going to be a you know already probably
is kind of a mess already but but
there's going to be a bigger mess
um and then it's like who is going to
adjudicate all the conflicts that will
arise between these two agencies well
presumably he might find it quite
helpful so you might find it quite
helpful to be above that and adjudicate
between different factions in the same
way that Mao did I'm sorry one one thing
if I could just add about Taiwan and the
language
um because I in the
party the revised party Constitution
there is language added about resolutely
and opposed resolutely opposed into per
separatists seeking Taiwan Independence
that I think is new language and so
there is some thought that that might
signal say some sort of a Taiwan
national security law that they passed
it would would
um but in terms of like a timeline
provision again it's it just I just want
to go back to this point because you
hear it all over DC that they're moving
up their timeline and so far nobody
seems to have any actual evidence it's
all based on analytical assessments it
could be right but there is a bit of a
frenzy here in DC now
um about sort of it's happening faster
and you also don't want to say it's
impossible because what if it does
happen because it's not impossible to
Victor's point you know you could
certainly look at the way he's he's sort
of laid out the the personnel and said
he's got to make some really big
decisions that basically you know that
are very momentous decisions and it's
going to be much easier now in this kind
of a setup so it is concerning this is
very much an aside and it's not strictly
Chinese business related but do you
think that the foreign policy community
and the intelligence community in DC are
feeling pretty confident in their
predictions these days given that they
think that they called the Russian
invasion right and so own Taiwan they
said they're also feeling relatively
confident
I hope not
um I mean I no because I I don't think I
don't think that we actually I mean I
wish it were funny but I don't think
that actually like like from from at
least from the Public Accounts the the
US and Allied out intelligence
um you know Allied countries had
actually quite good intelligence into
the reside into the into Putin's
decision-making process and intentions I
don't think we have anything like that
around she and I think that we're all
struggling you know public and then I
think in the classified world
from everything I hear and again I don't
know in the classified World wherever
they hear there there's not there used
to be much better streams of information
and now it's much harder to figure out
and I think that that again is I think
she she got when she took power he
realized that
that foreign intelligence agencies had a
lot of access and a lot of insight into
what was going on and he's very uh
intentionally uh cracked down on a lot
of of a lot of uh Espionage and I think
some of the big corruption cases will
turn out to have actually been about
these guys selling secrets okay and back
to the Congress then because it's been
you know a more dramatic one than I
think people were expecting you know we
started the Saturday before the congress
with this public protest from this
single man in Beijing on uh one of the
bridges one of the road Bridges with a
banner of various things that they did
not want and the things that they did
one was very clearly aimed at the
authoritarian regime and seceding ping
himself
then the week after we had putting tile
former president in a act where he was
forcibly escorted from the people's uh
Great Hall of the people so it's been
more dramatic I think than the kind of
properly choreographed Congress then
that the party wanted
um bill can we talk about the housing
tile incident because there's so many
theories flying around about what
exactly happens there
um bill first give us your to give us
your take on what happened there
I wish I knew
um honestly no I mean there's a longer
video that came out like Monday night
um clearly Houston Tao was uh disturbed
about something
um he is sick he has Parkinson's he's
had diabetes for a long time you know my
first pass I had a dad and a stepdad I
had dementia
um you know my first pass was there was
something going on cognitively that he
sort of got upset about and you can get
really irrational when that happens and
that would be the sort of more benign
explanation for what happened he was
um but I think I think there there are a
couple takeaways regardless of what
really happened is one it was
humiliating
um it just it just was a really bad look
Julian is he completely lost face yeah
on Julian and it was also the the other
leadership didn't look great because I
mean lijian XU actually looked like he
was trying to help him Legions who look
like sort of like he had some sense of
humanity the rest of the the rest of the
folks up there just either totally
ignored it or just kind of nodded like
ah like just you know wave them away I
think the other point though is it is it
is just the perfect symbol for the
um the destruction of any sort of power
centers related to who's in town
um it shows up in the it shows up in the
personnel and so it's it's just again a
sort of an end of an era
um in terms of what happened
you know
we we may never know there are various
stories going around there are people
who are convinced that it was a more
um malign event that there was something
that was agreed to that she's giving
changed around personnel and who's all
got upset about
we don't know it's certainly possible uh
you know one thing to look at
potentially is his son who haifung is a
delegate and he's uh he's the party
Secretary of a city in John province
If there really is something going on
will he have problems in a few months
maybe not tomorrow
and he was in a hall watching that
happen watching this happen to his dad
it must have been very difficult
personally so I wish we do but but I
will say and I'll throw the Victor is
just if if if the the darker scenario
where there was something going on where
she changed something or manipulated the
process in a way that was a surprise so
who's in town and then this is what
happened and I'm not saying that is what
happened I'm saying we can't rule it out
at this point then that matters because
it matters in terms of what kind of a
leader Xi Jinping is and it matters
especially to foreign governments about
how you assess what are we dealing with
in terms of the top leader so I hope we
find out the answer I I don't know yeah
I mean I don't know if we'll ever find
out an answer yeah but Victor what's
your best guess uh yeah no I mean it
seemed like he was Disturbed um you know
when he opened up this red folder uh and
started looking at it there's one
speculation actually my students uh were
like well you know because Xi Jinping
himself hadn't opened up the red folder
to look at it you know and it's
presumably just the list of the new
Central Committee members
uh then no one could open it up and
because he started opening it up uh he
was breaking the rule
um but I think to me even if that were
the case I mean hujin Tao was the
Secretary General of the Chinese
Communist Party
he should be given certain degree of
respect and for him to like you know
whether it's because of Parkinson or
because he's upset or whatever he starts
looking at it
um then almost immediately he gets
escorted out uh that's a very extreme
thing
uh and you know again I I thought yeah
very revealing the scene where Lee
janshu try to help but then while huning
pulled him back being one of those who's
now staying on the standing committee
and has survived three different
communist leaders right so he knows what
it takes right to to survive
um so so that makes me think that at
least for one who name he must have
interpreted as a very political event
and that he knew that whoever helped uh
can potentially be implicated in this
you know that this event this political
event
uh this level of like paranoia is really
just like the Mao period you know
I mean where everyone is so afraid of
fun tour right you know make a mistake
and and we really are kind of back to
that certainly in the elite uh but that
will filter down to Chinese Society
and what's and it also wasn't very
confusion sorry it wasn't that I didn't
drag drag the old leader away I know
that's my that's right I scored him away
he wasn't dragged he was he was I used
that word on Twitter as well I mean he
clearly was pulled lifted out of his
chair out of his chair as if he was a
doll and then just kind of pulled aside
um I think what's incredible as well is
Lika Town's lack of reaction
because you know you mentioned the
Central Committee nameless which are
which some theories say that that's what
um causing tar was trying to look at
Lucas and the current Premier of China
wasn't on that list so he not only he's
no longer Premier he's no longer
understanding committee he's not a
politburo he's not even on a Central
Committee and Niko town was one of those
who proteges but Lee just looked
Straight Ahead he was clearly did not
want to have any public demonstration
that he had anything to do with us at
all
because there there's something worse
awaiting him potentially which is a jail
cell
and he certainly didn't want that uh and
yeah so so this is what I mean you know
everyone's so afraid of making a mistake
you know fans who
that they could not display certainly
cannot display any kind of politically
meaningful gesture but even kind of
normal
you know human being helping another
human being they were afraid of doing
that also
well no but I mean it's very dark
because basically if they're treating
each other like this you know how do you
think they're going to treat the people
of China
if Xi Jinping words water some extreme
policies they will not hesitate
let's talk about that and as the final
you know wrap-up point which is now that
we now see is going to be in place for
at least another term or however long he
wants to be unless he gets ousted but it
seems as we say the party is terrified
of him what is that bringing in terms of
policy both for China and for the world
bill
um well I think
um from a policy perspective so for the
rest of the world again I don't think
we're going to see much deviation from
the sort of current trajectory it
certainly makes accelerate or or
um deepen but you've got the the main
backdrop is uh growing competition with
the US with increasing risk of some sort
of a conflict and and that's in every
domain
uh yeah so there you know there was a
lot of wording on technological
competition
uh you know achieving Supremacy but you
know now that all the legal channels for
China to acquire U.S technologies have
been closed off
what do you think will happen you know
the illegal channels will will have to
be intensified uh so that's going to be
a point of contention obviously between
two countries
um so you know one point I've been
making is that because Xi Jinping is
truly truly The Dictator
it is very important for uh you know the
president of the United States and other
senior officials
to get opportunities to talk to him as
much as possible and also the same thing
for Europe and Japan and other major
countries
uh because we just don't know the kind
of information about the United States
about other countries are going that are
landing on XI jinping's desk
and you know this information can be
incredibly distorted
um and so if anything just presenting an
alternative view of how the world Works
to him is going to be helpful he he may
not believe you you know of course his
advisors would be oh these are
imperialist lies and all that kind of
stuff but if you're able to look him in
the eye and tell him something uh at
least he'll be forced to think about it
you know
um and that he may be less likely to
make very rash decisions
uh but not talking to him which is
basically what happened in the latter
Trump years
um it's just a very dangerous course to
pursue for both sides
um and so I'm glad that these kind of
meetings have resumed and
um you know we have had a couple of
Biden meetings uh the one that's planned
hopefully it still will take place
despite you know everything
um
so I think these meanings
are are very important
Victor Bill thank you so much for
joining Chinese Whispers thanks for
listening Chinese Whispers is a podcast
brought to you by The Spectator and if
you'd like to listen to more just search
Chinese Whispers wherever you get your
podcast from and if you like what we do
here you might be interested in the
Chinese Whispers newsletter that I will
be launching in the near future sign up
for free at spectator.co.uk forward
slash Whispers And you'll be getting
regular updates from me on the most
interesting political and cultural news
from China as well as of course a
smattering of History that's
spectator.co.uk forward slash Whispers
[Music]
thank you